president Trump and his lawyers may be
heading toward a confrontation with the
special council leading the probe into
the Russian election meddling the
president just lost two members of his
legal team others are looking for ways
to push back against Robert Muller's
investigation which is now looking at
the financial affairs of the president
and the Trump Organization major carrots
at the White House
major good morning good morning
president Trump's strident criticism of
Attorney General Jeff Sessions raised
questions about just how comfortable he
is with an independent Justice
Department dealing with the Russia
investigation sessions for his part
gamely brushed aside questions yesterday
about whether he would or should resign
saying he will stay on the job as long
as it is appropriate he should have told
me before he took the job and I would
have picked somebody else just a day
after President Trump lashed out at
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and
Special Counsel robert muller in a New
York Times interview he lost two members
of his legal team the Office of the
President is entitled to expect loyalty
personal lawyer mark Kassovitz who
represented the president in all matters
concerning the Russia investigations is
out replaced by newly appointed attorney
Ty Cobb Casa Woods's spokesman mark
Corallo also resigned the shake-up comes
as mullahs rush investigation is
expanding to the president's personal
and family financing causing frustration
for mr. Trump who warned Muller would be
crossing a red line I think that's a
violation this is about the president's
lawyers have signaled that Muller is
overreaching but Muller's team has a
broad legal mandate to cover quote any
matters that arose or may arise directly
from the investigation including decades
of Trump family business dealings with
Russia you know sell a lot condo units
somebody somebody from Russia buys a
condo
I don't make money from Russia it's not
my thing I don't I don't do that over
the years I've looked at maybe doing a
deal in Russia I never do Jay Sekulow
one of the presidents attorneys denied
published reports that the president and
his legal team are exploring the
possibility of pardons in the Russia
investigation telling CBS News quote
pardons are not being discussed and are
not on the table CBS News is also
confirmed the Special Counsel is
investigating the overseas business
dealings of former Trump campaign
chairman Paul Manafort viana major
Garrett congratulations on your scoop as
well on the shake-up in the legal team